hello welcome to this video Ches ftv FTW
are sorry so when English opening
varying my opening see a little bit okay
that is the sorrentinos variation I
haven't looked at this for ages back
then it was supposed to be pretty okay
for white okay let's just develop him
I'm threatening Bishop g5 now winning
the Queen so he has to react to that yep
and he did so what now just castles
something else Queenie to for every
Queen each only for possible Bishop
reform
yeah I wonder if Bishop f three years
some kind of move prolly not that parade
even though structurally speaking at
term and terms very weakening for me now
light squares don't look particularly
good c 7 mm and d7 both were under check
i can play maybe you look be one
threatening c5
hmm
yeah let's try maybe Queen g6 here or
something like that right that's pretty
pretty risky move okay just went back so
can I go see 5c 5 pawn takes rook b8
queen bee 8d takes you five Bishop takes
Knight inch five this kind of stuff it
looks pretty dangerous so let's do this
if you go screen be one up canceling
that looks bad we should see 595 looks
pretty winning actually for white
well it looks bad I don't see how we
save this now so 95 is there a playable
move don't see any Queen D H or can't
see it yeah I can cancel on now for luke
t 1 and F 696 is also just willing 26
next 27 collapses black resigns hmm
rights dangerous opening I think
probably he has to do something else I
mean here yes to improve maybe Ruby aid
this is already looking pretty pretty
awkward I think what Queen g6 or queena
five okay that was a that was a moment
where I wasn't absolutely sure what
would happen okay the engine gives this
fact that makes quite some sense of
course overprotecting d7 so that c5
Nancy five is not not leading to
anything I mean taking here but even
drops III so okay probably have to
cancel and then black also castles yeah
and if we both castle everything's okay
if I'm probably about equal yeah okay so
then this was a problem I guess c5 I ok
Bishop e7 is still kind of playable and
intending to do this okay
with this this led to us right yeah that
loses oops cast lots was better but yeah
I had bishop f6 now the arrow came okay
and this is a pretty strong wolf check
why do we win yeah it's it's a bit bit
much yeah at him I'm just winning
everything he's six is hanging and made
on his seven then and so on plus the
rulings of course yeah it was a pretty
pretty drastic loss but he could have
defended much much better than in the
opening as we have seen yet to make a
couple of wrong decisions to really get
into that trouble okay well thanks for
watching